we start with congratulations on your
movie thanks very much appreciate that
listen George and Julia are they're
movie stars they're selective with what
they do what is it like actually getting
the phone call or the zoom meeting or
whatever it may be when they actually
say yeah we're going to do this it was
extraordinary and in this case it was
particularly high stakes because I wrote
it for them it was conceived for them
and written for them and then I sent it
to both of them at the same time which
you never do because then if one of them
passes the other one will get insecure
and pass as well do you know what I mean
and so um but I sent it to both of them
going this only works if it's the power
of you and I'm not going to make the
movie otherwise and so it was really
high stakes even higher than normal and
then um but in a way that's a kind of
nice get out for me because obviously
they're going to pass and then they
could go oh well shame I don't have to
make a movie I can just imagine it in my
head and that'll be great so it was
terrifying to get the call that it was
um yeah subject to another call it was
on
um terrifying you have you've done
obviously other projects I have did you
find that this was the one that more
friends and family were begging you to
visit you on set yeah except that it was
in Australia and so with the with the
two-week um quarantine so no one could
come and so um yes everybody wants to
come and everyone let's press and our
friends on her work for germis wanted to
come but um nobody could and so um yeah
we were just in a tunnel we vanished I
vanished for six months so it left home
like everyone I love the beer pong scene
and them dancing I know everyone talks
about it but I'm curious what is it like
directing that scene where you're
directing those two trying to the beer
pong and the day like what is it it's
amazing it was the best night the best
working I have had and I did Mamma Mia
like I did you know I put Sharon a
helicopter and this was even more fun
than that it was um it was amazing and
you kind of I mean I had a I had a mic a
radio control thing to talk to all the
different cameramen because you're
trying to you know you don't have long
that you know obviously they've got
energy but you don't have that long to
try and capture it so but I think it
wasn't attached to any this thing I
think like Sid Vicious is based so they
just used to unplug it so he would just
play whatever rubbish and you know then
take heroin and no one would ever know
how bad he was and I think I think I was
shouting go left pan left focus on Julia
and no one did anything that I said so
it was great for me I just panicked and
shouted uh I'm always curious about the
editing because that's where it all
comes together sure so how did this film
possibly change in the editing room in
ways you did not expect to be honest
very little it was very it came out okay
it just it came out quite smooth it got
a little shorty you lose things that
don't work and also you realize how good
they are so you realize you've
overwritten do you know what I mean you
realize that you've given them lines to
explain something that they're so good
at just showing you that you don't need
the line of explanation I mean so you
know it tightened but it didn't it
didn't radically I think we were ready
for it to change but it yeah it was okay
it worked out all right what I mean
you've obviously directed many people
very famous actors but what is it like
what kind of Direction on set do you
like to give an actor when you need
something to different are you like a
few words are you having full-on
conversations different actors you're
trying very you know they're very needy
actors that need you to intervene and be
quite Stern or be whatever and there are
actors that you just you know George I
would go that too that was my main note
to him every now and then I just do that
and you get too big and I just you know
and then he you know so um uh but then
you know just a different actors it
varies but I mean in general with these
guys they so know what they're doing
that I would just I'm just there to
laugh and appreciate and go maybe try
this one and I'll try it and it's better
the way they did it the first time I I
am definitely curious if you put it in
your contract that um you would get a
piece of the residuals of all the people
going to Bali after seeing this no I
don't and I don't I mean I just I don't
even go to Barley myself I mean it's
shot in Australia I thought you know
because obviously you're a Sumo movie is
not going to happen so I thought at
least I'd get two research trips out of
it to Barney but I still haven't been so
um uh extraordinarily because of the
pandemic we weren't able to get we had a
crew shooting there so they were
shooting backdrops and we would see
during them in but
um yeah no listen if people go great
amazing Barney's had a really tough time
so if we can help in any way it you know
We Gather in research then that would be
brilliant uh my last question for you
it's totally cool
um if you had uh and people want to make
movies with you so this might not apply
but if you could get the financing to
make anything you want what would you
make and why God that's terrifying um my
next film is always the next one and so
another thing I've written a movie that
I think is going to happen uh next
spring but I'd like the money's not
totally certain obviously you always
want more money because you want more
time it's not like it doesn't it's not
my money but you have that gives you
more time and more space and more room
to create so um I'd like the money to
come together for that one please that
would be nice I think it'll happen thank
you put a good positive things I
appreciate that on that note congrats on
the movie I know it's going to be ahead
thank you I appreciate it